[Musique]
il n'y en a pas sur 100 chantait léo
ferré et pourtant les 68 à semble-t-il
redonner des couleurs au drapeau noir
comme aux apatrides de la révolte
avant d'être un historien a reconnu de
l'autogestion michel antony s'est fait
la main avec d'autres en prenant le
contrôle de son école c'était au mois de
mai il n'avait pas 18 ans on a vécu le
moment libertaire dans la pratique c'est
la pratique que l'idée de te gestion
d'eau après on va en bar et moi-même
notamment avec des lectures qui me
recherche sur faculté je vais élever
seul édifié tout ça mais on se chante 8
on vit naturellement l'auto-organisation
alicia grévistes qui va vivre un
événement inhabituel
ces jours là le 13 mai moi ça m'a
particulièrement marqué parce que mon
père qu'elle gendarmes sur valentigney
il est mobilisé à besançon et le matin
du 13 mai ya un gendarme tout 1 h et qui
via l'entrée l'école normale les copains
d attention ça y est on vient vous
arrêter et puis c'est mon père qui l'a
m'embrasser quoi ça c'est ça c'est
étonnant c'est et layton
ennuyé par mon action frangins même
moment un travail chez peugeot him
il est dans les pick up chez peugeot on
pert est menacée ladhuie recquois ya
jamais progresser nos jeunes hommes et y
à cause de ça ou pays de pros dont les
anarchistes ont pignon sur rue avec
leurs librairies l'autodidacte plutôt
discret traditionnellement peu causant
avec les médias trois d'entre eux ont
toutefois accepté d'évoquer le joli mois
de mai moi j'avais 16 ans aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui m'a amené à l'anarchisme
mois sur 68 g g t sur les épaules de mon
père dans les manifestations à sochaux à
l'époque j'étais expliqué plus
meyrannais d'architecturé marisa est une
anarchiste italienne elle était à
florence en 68
mêmes causes mêmes batailles c'était un
société qu'il là c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d espace à tout ça qu'ils étaient les
sujets des jeunes de la vie d'échangés
de vivre autre chose et il l'était il
était vraiment figé et il l'avait cette
cocotte qui bouillait et qu'il avait les
besoins d'aidé sécuritaire parce que
tenait plus ce ne sont pourtant pas ces
images de fin de mois difficiles qui
vont incarnait la résistance où l'utopie
se sont plutôt celles ci quelques années
plus tard lors du conflit pts mais déjà
la désillusion gâte mois après 68 ils
ont commencé à préparer le programme
commun et on peut dire que tout finit
avec l'élection de mitterrand 80 et la
cmc 1
c'est à partir de ce moment le
capitalisme triomphant en tant
qu'artiste tank anarcho syndicaliste on
n'a pas d'église d'accord on peut aller
où on veut à partir du moment où il ya
la lutte de classe et où on revendique
certaines idées et l'a à nouveau on a
recréé un groupe à la cgt moi je ne me
revendique anarcho syndicaliste d'autres
sont plutôt parti communiste d'autres
sont plutôt ou npa des militants peu
nombreux mais toujours très présents
c'était encore le cas ce jour là pour
soutenir des étudiants convoqués par la
justice
heureusement beaucoup de soixante
huitard entre autres cohn-bendit par
exemple complètement retourné leur veste
et maintenant sont devenus des vieux
cons conservateur je pouvais pas être
autre chose que moi donc j'étais liberté
[Musique]
michel antony lui aussi n'a jamais lâché
prise
il se bat aujourd'hui pour défendre les
migrants mais aussi les services publics
dans son département la haute saône je
me dis tout leur liberté je me dis pas
d'un schiste libertaire oui je pense que
les vertex la liberté c'est l'essentiel
liberté de pensée liberté d'agir
il a été critiqué y compris ceux de son
propre camp et surtout son propre camp
s'ils font des conneries ça j'ai
toujours fait
[Musique]